[Music]
Natacha my sister after all this time
what brings you home
[Applause]
I was trying to do something doing
are you more than just a trained killer
you're fooling yourself we're still both
trained killers
we have unfinished business
[Music]
as we
stupid family back together again you
got fat it smelly water way
there's a new Walter what else
nube enemies
I'm done running for my past
[Music]
the hell is that guy
I said nothing
[Music]
come on I got this job this family
but nothing lasts forever
heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
and now you're out there I know you know
I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what we are
it's good to see - says what brings you
home
business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
I'm still family back together again you
got fat
[Music]
black widows multilayered and you know
motivated and determined and all of
those things and she has an art I would
love to take this character in every
different direction you're always
picking up after you boys the
possibilities are really endless before
I worked for shield make mistakes but
I'm done running from my past very few
actors can say that they've worked on a
character for ten years and then
suddenly have this chance to delve deep
into the inner workings of this person
we have to go back to where it all
started there's one movie people have
been asking us to make for very long
time more so than any other film black
widow movie
we're gonna be able to create something
that is a different flavor for the
Marvel Universe I'm just excited to see
that real Black Widow she's not a
classic hero because she has a dark past
what brings you home you get to see all
these facets of her that we've never
ever seen before we have unfinished
business
one thing's for sure it's gonna be a
hell of a reunion Marvel Studios Black
Widow in theaters May 1st
[Music]